Egyptian museum officials while
overseeing restoration of artifacts
damaged in a late January looting
incident now say several objects are
missing from the museum among items
missing a gilded wood statue of King Tut
being carried by a goddess a gilded wood
statue of King Tut harpooning this item
was broken in the January incident and
only the top portion is missing and
another missing item is a limestone
statue of Akhenaten holding an offering
table in all 18 items were reported
missing minister of Antiquities aji
Hawass had earlier said nothing was
stolen from the Egyptian Museum in Cairo
but in a February 12th statement
confirms the items were missing he also
stated quote I have said if the egyptian
museum is safe then egypt is safe
however I am now concerned Egypt is not
safe